guys this movie just when i thought i
knew where it was going i was completely
blown away did you feel that way when
you're reading the script were you like
what is happening
100
every page i was going what is going to
happen next i thought i was at the
ending and then
i wasn't
it was just it was a roller coaster it
was it was great yeah i i i signed on to
the movie like halfway through the
script because i was just so taken by it
and then i finished the script and
i was even more taken by it because it
was it was awesome and there's so many
uh exciting things that happened without
trying not to spoil it
yeah no absolutely i think it's such a
really interesting question that this
movie asks is it okay to watch so what's
your take on that
i don't think we should i feel like it's
okay to watch the movie yeah
i don't want to watch the movie good
answer
i'll want the audience to have so i
don't want to put our own
bias into their mind going into it i
want to see what everyone thinks because
i think the movie explores both answers
to that question
you know um so we'll see what their
everyone says exactly
guys that's a very good answer they're
giving anything away i love that now
obviously with this being an erotic
thriller you've got your steamy moments
in this film so what was it like
shooting the more intimate scenes
uh we got to work with the intimacy
coordinator named amanda who's nice
incredible who worked with sydney on
euphoria which i didn't know oh that's
nice you didn't know that no i did not
know that yeah actually i think i did
know that but i forgot
and now i've
remembered um yeah she's great she's
great um so intimate scenes are intimacy
scenes are a lot like
um
choreography
yeah i just know what i just realized
this was my first intimacy scene
really
is that truth am i i think that's true
you did a good job
i'm so i'm so like honored
like
yeah anyways uh i really just
remember that right now is that true i
need to look back in my brain but um but
yeah so intermittent scenes are a lot
like choreography technical yeah very
technical you know everything is
rehearsed you know exactly where your
hands are going and what's happening and
the movement that's happening and she's
there to make sure that
it stays that way yeah exactly and
there's no exploring
exactly
and no one no one is uh
is crossing the line crossing the line
or uh doing anything that wasn't
previously discussed um
and so she's there to make you feel
comfortable but then she's also there to
make sure that it looks good and real
yeah like it's like it's that balance of
like technicality and choreography and
then also like you still have to make it
look like it's good
like you start to make it believable you
know i mean
um so when you guys watch those scenes
back you're like okay yeah that really
worked
uh yes um
yeah
i mean like this is his first time i
can't answer this question yet
it's a testament well then i went and
did a generation where i do like
hundreds of interviews but um but yeah
like uh you know i remember on the day
we watched it we went it was so playback
well yeah mike was like i just gotta
show you something yeah
and i just wanna we weren't even
connecting yeah
that's amazing
yeah so that was a little awkward but in
the final film it looks great
no i'm absolutely um you know sydney
it's been so much fun watching recent
projects people still can't stop talking
about the finale of the white lotus of
course people can't wait for euphoria
season two now you've got the lawyers
how does that feel being like the it
girl in hollywood right now
oh i don't know i don't know
[Music]
did i put pressure too much pressure now
i don't i i i never feel like i'm doing
enough so i don't feel that i think that
there's always way more for me to work
hard towards and achieve and
push myself for so i don't
know what movie's about
well it must be pretty exciting you know
you put a project out there and you're
like i hope people like it but the
projects you're putting out there seem
to be really well received by people
i
i
i tried
i mean there's way more than just me
that goes into these things
yeah but you're definitely like i mean
on top of you just being awesome at your
job
for all of these projects have you ever
considered that because thank you
the through line everything that sydney
sweeney does is great and successful and
big
and so don't change i know i'm jinxing
this move you know
i'm jinxing you too
you guys so much fun getting to talk to
you congratulations on this film it was
really really good
thank you
you